so let's get right into it
yeah Scott you gave resin equals seven
biohazard an eight out of ten on your
review I did it's just as good as yuccas
a zero no in the same ways that's what
eight out of ten mean yeah there was
very little sexual release in Resident
Evil anyways for me so I enjoyed resin
seven a lot so you you feeding it as
well now right I did yeah I did it in
two sittings which I don't recommend but
that's the thing about resin evil seven
before I get your opinion I think the
pacing is really good like you mentioned
you review some sections dragged I do
agree but even though section I was I
really really like that you know we're
gonna have what spoilers but throughout
the game it's pretty impressive how
Capcom kind of stuck to its survival
horror guns yeah totally throughout the
game it it's not resi with six it's not
five or four yeah not even a little bit
it's seven as the number denotes yeah
even though sections that kind of drag
you still want to know what comes next
right so you're like okay I'm gonna slog
through this because I care and because
like whatever is next is like I want to
get there whether through gameplay or
story because for the first time in this
series spin-offs or numbered the stories
comprehensible yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's still a little outlandish in places
because this resident like he gets a
little silly but like it was never so
silly that I was like this is just dumb
it was just like okay like I would
accept the conceit and move on and yeah
ultimately it is like as far as Resident
Evil's concerned a very grounded story a
story that makes sense from start to
finish there is this cute cohesion to
the entire experience and it totally
goes some places I did not expect that's
great it wasn't just a you know like
like I put it in the review without
spoiling too much there is more to this
game than what you have seen of it so
far for sure yeah cuz right now it's
just that very text exchange Texas
Chainsaw Massacre vibe there are some
clear influences from other like
specific horror franchises that goes
into this and just the pimp it I'm gonna
do it a lot because it's really good
tomorrow Hussein UK editor and Adam
Mason over in the UK and collaboration
with a couple people here who helped
they did a one of our game spot studios
documentary series the two-part series
on making res evil 7 and also just
resonable series influenced as a whole
on the horrors
we talked to a bunch of people that
worked on press evil seven which is kind
of a all-star team of grass evil
pasteurizing evil devs massachio Kawada
Zanna attack eug worked on present evil
seven and the series is really good you
should go watch it honking spots on
YouTube out tomorrow did a really good
job behind the scenes stuff just a lot
of insight spoke to Dan Pinchbeck from
the Chinese room who made a Mei machine
for pigs he was a great interview and
also uh someone from alien isolation his
name escapes me right now he was like
head on in isolation I wish I knew his
name but also Mattias Warsh from dead
space how resting before and also the
earlier games influenced that space but
yeah go check that out there's my first
of probably several plugs for that
series it's fantastic you should watch
it um absolutely and we've actually done
a few series like that but like this may
be the best one it's it's really
genuinely some of the best content we've
yeah it's really good if you like
Resident Evil it is especially awesome
what's interesting though is I think
Resident Evil and part of the excitement
around returning to survival horror
right and getting back to the series
roots it is just such a recognizable
name it is like an inescapable part of
gamer culture at large so maybe people
who aren't necessarily horror fans
Resident Evil fans I think might
actually get something out of that
series just because of how influential
the aura games were I mean years before
yeah there's war and dead space and all
these other franchises the horror and
otherwise yeah absolutely were
influenced by Resident Evil so it's
weird they dropped off I mean it's not
weird it dropped them and Silent Hill
dropped off the map the kind of the two
flagship horror series and you know now
a resin evil sevens back in a good way
it's getting pretty positive reception
across the board yeah my ate was on the
low end yeah for most the scores that I
was seeing right I think I saw one seven
I forget where it was but everything
else was pretty high yeah so just to go
back to your review in terms of to get
into the details what do you like I
don't know walk us through what your
experience was it after you finished the
game what was kind of going through your
head I mean like I said I did it in a
day which it's like a 12-hour game
they're saying give or take an hour yeah
I mean I could see beating it I mean you
go I think you said you beaten like
seven like seven innocence save time was
seven and a half I think I spent like
nine on it okay that sounds but I also
as a I played for hours this for the rez
Newell seven studios to help out with
and so you kind of use some of the posit
that section I kind of knew what I was
doing gotcha but there are puzzle in
this game but not that hard but like
navigating the mansion and other places
is part of what's gonna take a little
bit but the backtracking worked I think
yeah I mean there's not there's not too
much of it and it's like 90 percent if
it's optional it's basically oh hey you
now have a key that opens the door that
you walk past you want to go get some
more items like go for it go back and
get that stuff but you don't you don't
need it it'll just help you um so I
think that that was a wise choice on
their part by and large it is a
relatively linear experience I mean
there's actually sort of a hub-and-spoke
structure to certain parts of the game
where you can you know shoot out and do
something and come back to your little
like safe spot and then go out again and
do something but yeah still like the
series of events there's really only one
next thing to do at any given time so it
really drives the experience forward
makes it very clear what you need to be
doing so yeah I didn't I didn't mind the
backtracking at all it really was just
the survival horror like hey if you need
more stuff and if you were patient go
back and get it or just forge ahead and
take chances sure to use an overworked
overused term kind of Metroidvania
aspects or castle droid as counsel
stated I think that's fair spock came up
with that castle right yeah I can't say
Nia I think Jeremy parish the the
journalist popularized it but I think in
a recent thing about Symphony of the
Night which actually has its 20th
anniversary in March I think we're gonna
do something fun with that
he was saying he didn't actually coin it
was someone else at us gamer or
something I thought it was probably at
that time for him one up right oh yeah
who's your former went up as well as
Justin is yeah I was I didn't work that
close with Jeremy gotcha
anyway but yes in terms of backtracking
into editing out new areas no no no no I
yeah it's actually a it the game itself
anytime I backtracked it felt there's
still more items I hadn't picked up or
there's always something going through
my head in terms of do I want to use
this chem fluid to make handgun ammo or
should I save it for health if I think
I'm coming up on a boss fight or
something it's that cool that's survival
which the item management which hasn't
really been present resin evil since for
but in a big way since like the first
three games yeah totally
yeah inventory management definitely
makes a big return and I mean it also
just that
enhances the tension in a lot of ways
right because you know one enemy swipes
at you and like it's not gonna kill you
but just that one hit hurts so much more
because yah now I'm gonna have to spend
a healing item to recover my health and
like I don't know when I'm gonna get
another one so even even little moments
that aren't going to kill you or force
you to restart are suddenly way more
high-stakes just because of the
inventory management because
everything's so scarce right
can I ask you little bit question yeah
so I'm about hour and a half into the
game and it seems like health items have
been pretty plentiful so does that
continue I will say that so the hardest
difficulty you can play on out of the
box is normal brand new eventually
unlock something harder but on normal I
feel like the game is consistently
generous enough that if you are patient
and vigilant you will always find what
you need yeah like if you're just
blazing through you will die and run out
of items but if you are taking your time
and you're meticulously searching rooms
yeah you will find enough stuff that is
what I'm doing okay
yeah I am like turning over every stone
is to make sure I would say that on
normal there's a pretty pretty good
balance of being tense without being
punishing I still feel like I don't want
to use my items but frankly like when I
do and then I'm like okay I'll find one
in the next room and it's like all right
I guess I shouldn't have cared so much I
do think that that drops off a little
bit the further you get in but not
significantly it should reach a point in
the game where it's like suddenly you
have nothing and you're just screwed
haha like no it's but I do feel like the
frequency does decline as you would
expect yes should the later you get in
the game no more difficult it's gonna be
the higher the stakes the higher the
tension the better you should be yeah
absolutely
and you do get better like you well you
sort of learn how to fight the enemies
that you face in the game and like that
was actually sort of one of my issues
with the game that I feel like just sort
of the basic enemies that you encounter
the game could have been a little more
capable once you sort of understand them
you realize like I can just want to
right run away from these idiots like
whatever not always the case but if you
see them from a distance you're like I'm
not gonna fight you I don't and you just
kind of run away and how persistent our
enemies depends on the enemy there's
game II thing if you play a lot of resin
evils you know that they'll abide by the
rule that if you're in a safe room they
won't go in so you know that so much but
like there's some you know like in the
the manner you start off right there's a
lot like especially around the kitchen
in the dining room the
like there's a lot of like space
therefore that are connected I know one
person Karen will follow you
relentlessly but oh there are some
sections that are more like resonable 3
nemesis kind of a persistent threat not
throughout the game though I'd say by
and large most of the game there are
enemies tied to certain areas well they
like so if I leave that area will the
enemy still be there when I go back so
here's here's what I'll say I think that
Resident Evil 7 does a really excellent
job of seamlessly stitching together a
bunch of different components and you
don't realize that you've actually
transitioned from one section of the
game into the next section yeah and
different sections are governed by
different enemies and different sort of
like AI in a way so there there will be
a section where there's almost a tyrant
like character who will just
relentlessly come after you and there
are other sections where it behooves you
to be a little stealthier just because
that's what's going to work for you yeah
and again you don't it's not explicit
it's not like you know a big prompt
comes up and says hey you need to be
stealthy here but you just sort of as a
character intuitively understand what's
happening around you and suddenly the
gameplay will pivot slightly and now
you're in this other type of section so
really depends on the the portion of the
game that you're in ok it's really yeah
it is really fluid in how it goes from
one type of horror like jump scares to
another which is more dread and being
chased and then to another one where
you're like do I want to use this
advanced handgun ammo to kill this enemy
or do I want to say the shotgun for the
next room are there gonna be booby traps
in this room it does you put it really
well it does transition between those
without you really realizing it it makes
it feel like one cohesive game rather
than these separate sections like these
kind of bite-sized
you know like mini chapters which
totally kind of is but it but it doesn't
there's no like a there's not like a
chapter marker oh you're done they just
fluidly moves to the next thing I will
say that just in general variety is one
of the core strengths of Resident Evil 7
again certain sections kind of drag
after a while because you end up doing
similar things from start to finish but
in between you will find all kinds of
different subtle shades of horror
gameplay so it's nice that there are
options it's nice that there are
different approaches and different
styles of gameplay all sort of under the
same banner all presented in a seamless
way
sure yeah there were people asking
questions about the
Elsie's you guys worry too much about
that yeah the band footage DLC what is
this about you know so we have to check
the site to get like exact details but
basically it's going to be just sort of
standalone story segments so there are
going to be two packs of band footage
pack 1 pack 2 I believe the first ones
out in just a few weeks the next ones
out a few weeks after that so they're
both scheduled come out relatively soon
and both contain three different things
I think like two sort of story driven
components and one sort of fun bonus
mode in both cases I don't member
exactly what the content is but all of
it is sort of a supplement to the game
it's not really like and here is the
next chapter of the story like here is
the you know epilogue to the game it's
stuff that kind of slots into the
universe and is like just purely
optional we'll sort of flesh out other
characters that you interact with or
other you know stuff that happens prior
to the game things like that sure that's
my understanding of what's happening so
Photoshop Pro and the YouTube chat was
just asking and I actually don't want
you to answer this fully cuz I think I
could lean into spoilers but it does
give me a good question he says with a
demo part of the story and I'm assuming
I'm in the beginning our demo there's
also the lantern demo or is the full
game of continuation from the demo I
think that spoiler territory but you
were talking about how you thought it
was really cool about the pre-release
like marketing how that plays a part in
the story can you talk about that
without spoil anything
not really however I am absolutely I'm
already working on a feature that I
would so when you see this feature hit
the site I would recommend beating the
game before you you watch this but I do
think that the way Capcom handled sort
of their pre-release build up to this
game in a really interesting way that's
not unprecedented but is something that
I think is truly remarkable and actually
like I totally applaud the way that they
approach things yes um so if I really
explained what I mean I will be spoiling
things but I I do think that if you were
paying attention before the game come
out if you're playing the demo that
you're going to find some really cool
stuff in the game and you're gonna be
very happy that you were paying
attention before the game came out
awesome
so in terms of your review quick bullet
points before we had move on in the next
section you had bad overall thoughts
good variety good returned horror I
think it did an excellent job
I do think was paced well
some of the boss fights were really
amazing like true resident evil boss
fights the story is actually very good
surprisingly good it avoids a lot of
pitfalls that it could have easily
fallen into and instead to something
kind of unexpected and a lot of the
twists are predictable but it's so cool
to see them play out bad would be I do
think like I said certain sections kind
of drag where it's just like okay I just
want to get through this I don't
actually care about what I'm doing I
just want to get to the next thing that
happens a few times a couple of the boss
battles were actually more annoying than
intense and enjoy a phrase definitely
there's one in particular where you're
given a weapon just for that fight and I
kept dying over and over until the game
said by the way you can do a power
attack if you hit these buttons and as
soon as it told me that I won the fight
I actually need to tell you something
else about that fight that someone from
Capcom told me about oh yeah there's
something else that makes that fight
really easy really I didn't know about
it I didn't know about what you told me
until it yeah so I would inside baseball
ship yeah well always think mmm those
are the those are the big negatives I
wish they had done a little more with
puzzles there are a couple really great
puzzles in game I just wish there had
been more of them cool yes so go read
Scott's review it is up on GameSpot he
even ate a 10 I read evil 7 biohazard he
liked it a lot as a lot of outlets seem
to be corroborating that and myself as
well it's a great game Pete probably
play more of it soon I would soon yeah I
liked it a lot so far it's definitely
like a nice change of pace cool and we
got a few more resonable segments but
again watch our reviving resin evil
series tomorrow saying the UK editor did
a great job on that behind the scenes we
have a lot of guides going up soon like
what the beating the game will unlock
how new game+ works a guide for finding
antique coins these things that unlock
more abilities and weapons harrods and
evil ties into the broader universe yes
which we're actually about to get to in
a little bit so we're talking more about
how resonable fits into the resin evil
franchise but for all intents purposes
it seems like capcom has a winner on
their hands and maybe they're kind of
you know the series seems like it is
making a comeback which is great for
everyone so yeah go check those out the
site and leave your thoughts in the
comments will drive us to peruse them
and answer any questions we might not
have answered here
[Music]